foreign
you've heard the phrase move fast and
break things
Facebook made it famous but really Mark
just made the mistake of saying it out
loud and putting it on company posters
by the way Mark and I are not on a first
name basis
ing the first names of our leaders
reminds us that leadership is a practice
of imperfect humans leading imperfect
humans that's why it's so hard
how's it going Elon
move fast and break things is still a
widely held belief that we can either
make progress or take care of each other
one or the other
that a certain amount of wreckage is the
price we have to pay for inventing the
future
my wife and I have spent the last decade
helping companies clean up this wreckage
and one of the main lessons from our
work is that the trade-off at the heart
of this world view is false
the most effective leaders we know
solve problems at an accelerated Pace
while also taking responsibility for the
success and the well-being of their
customers and employees and shareholders
they move fast and fix things
now what's come out of our work as
something of a playbook for fixing
problems quickly whether it's a broken
company culture or a struggling
friendship
and so what I want to do with you today
is invite you to try on this Playbook
over the course of an imaginary week
so how this is going to work is I'm
going to give you an agenda for each day
of the week Monday Tuesday Wednesday you
see where this is going
and then I want you to go home and try
and see how much progress you can make
does that sound reasonable okay
I'm seeing some signs of consent thank
you
start by thinking of a problem that
you're having right now that involves at
least one other person your kids your
co-founders your customers Etc
now in our imaginary week
it's now Monday morning
now Monday morning it's a bad rap but we
like to think of it as the gift of
renewal that comes around every seven
days
on Monday your task is to figure out
what your real problem is which may not
be the problem that you thought you had
just a minute ago
because here's the thing
as human beings we tend to be
overconfident in the quality of our
thoughts
particularly when it comes to diagnosing
our own problems my investors don't get
it
my gen Z employees are entitled my dog
is mad at me
let's find out if you're right the thing
that's going to help you out most today
is your own curiosity so turn that
original diagnosis my gen Z employees
are entitled into a question rather than
a statement what's going on with my gen
Z employees
now your next move sounds obvious but
you might be surprised to learn how
infrequently people actually do it talk
directly to the other people who have a
stake in your problem
ask some things you might not normally
ask and polite company things that
require a little courage on your part
now as I look around the room and I'm
being a little presumptuous I suspect
this is going to be hard for some of you
I get it I come from a very waspy family
there were three approved topics of
conversation the pets the weather and
Tom broke off for some reason
but sometimes just a single Brave
conversation can reveal an entirely new
structure to your problem some of you
will discover for example that you have
a role to play in creating the problem
that you're now solving this week
instead of your gen Z employees being
entitled for example
you might discover it's you who feels
entitled
to burn them out and pay them less than
what they're worth simply because that
was the broken work contract that you
put up with at their age
I'm just I'm just I'm just spitballing
up here
but what I do know is that whatever it
is you learn today you're going to be
closer to understanding what's really
getting in the way of the relationship
or the organization or the life you want
all right excellent first day everyone
get some rest now it's Tuesday
on Tuesday your job is to run a smart
experiment in how to solve your problem
start by creating a good enough plan to
strengthen the relationship at the
center of it
now a good enough plan is distinct from
a perfect plan which is an elusive
Fantastical creature that has never
actually been spotted in the wild
we tend to think about problems through
the lens of trust so one prompt that
often helps on Tuesday is what could you
do tomorrow to build more trust than you
did today
for one team we were working with they
decided to stop texting each other about
each other in the middle of meetings
[Applause]
someone else we were coaching decided
that it was time to come clean to his
co-founders that he was ready to move on
from the business
another leader decided that it was time
for him to take full responsibility for
the unintended harms of a product that
he designed
is your good enough plan gonna work
probably not
statistically not on the first try
that's why I'm giving you all weeks to
figure it out
but also to make the inevitable
unavoidable mistakes
the purpose of Tuesday is not to get it
right the purpose of Tuesday is to learn
it's to get into the sandbox of your
life and give yourself permission to
play
all right go and have the adult beverage
of your choice which you have definitely
earned
now it's Wednesday
on Wednesday your job is to do something
that adults generally don't like to do
it's to make new friends
but the research is really clear that
whatever problem you're trying to solve
this week you're going to be better at
solving it with people who don't already
think like you do
I know you've heard this before many
times but today is your chance to
practice so describe your good enough
plan the one you came up with yesterday
to someone whose life experience has
been materially different from yours
if you've been at the company for a
decade talk to someone who started last
week
if you're a white partner talk to a
black partner if you're queer like me
talk to the straightest person you can
find
contrary to what you may have heard
recently they're everywhere
and when you're done with that
conversation have another conversation
with someone else who's different from
you on some other gorgeous dimension of
The Human Experience this is going to
take you all day
and some of you are going to be
surprised to discover that it's your
favorite day of the week at the end of
the day you're going to be smiling and
your good enough plan is going to be an
even better plan
okay now it's Thursday good morning
it's Thursday you're unstoppable
Thursday is storytelling day
as humans we need stories to make sense
of change to find our place in the
script of it
stories also help us to activate all the
other people around us whose help we're
going to need with that change stories
have three parts past present future
we often skip over that past part in
moments of big change
we did some work with Uber when it was
going through its very public crisis and
Leadership
and when the new guy came in the new CEO
and hosted his first All Hands meeting
he committed to retain The Edge that had
made Uber a force of nature
now this line was met with thunderous
Applause
the Applause of relief
he also joined in a standing ovation for
his predecessor who also happened to be
in the room that day
I was so struck
by the grace of this choice
and that's the word I want you to bring
to your own storytelling listen
Uber had
serious problems to solve is anyone
reading the news could figure out but
the people in that room had built
something extraordinary
and they had something real to lose in
an uncertain future
instead of setting himself up as some
kind of company savior
the new guy honored that complicated
truth honor the complicated truth of the
people around you the ones who aren't so
sure about all your big plans
then tell us why you want to change
things
finally tell us about the future in
Vivid and specific language tell us what
it's going to feel like when your story
becomes our reality
all right it's Friday
it's Friday and you're almost done I
promise
the payoff of Friday the payoff of this
whole week of hard work
is that you now get to move fast because
you're far less likely to break things
so do everything you decided to do over
the last week but now do it with a sense
of urgency
urgency releases the energy in a system
it makes it clear to everyone that you
take the problem seriously
so whatever administrative hurdles
whatever unproductive process is in the
way of taking action today just strip it
out just refuse to tolerate it
people ask us all the time about the
optimal timing for big change
and our answer is almost always the same
how about now
now seems good
take action now and then learn from
whatever happens next and at the end of
this day at the end of this week you're
even better Chan you're even better plan
has a chance of being a great plan
all right that's it
that's your week congratulations you did
it as you rest and recover which is
essential
I want to leave you with one final
thought
I spend my time helping leaders to
change and evolve and no one has ever
said to me I wish I had taken longer and
done less
what I do here again and again is the
opposite
and so my invitation to you today is to
practice to practice taking less time to
do more of the things that will make
your relationships
and your teams and your organizations
stronger
and to be honest you have my blessing to
take longer than a week to get it done
what I don't want you to do is to take
months or even years
which tends to be our default timeline
for solving hard problems
most of our problems deserve a more
Urgent Response
most of our problems deserve a metabolic
rate that honors the frustration and the
mediocrity and the real pain of the
status quo for some of you
thank you
so whether your name is Mark or Elon or
Chris thank you for having me or Anne
find out what happens when you move fast
and fix things and decide that the
moment that matters most is right now
thank you